the cream of the crop rose at the top on
sunday in tampa bay
we didn't expect it to go this way
especially when it was ten nothing
green bay packers over the tampa bay
buccaneers but the floodgates
opened and they stayed open to the tune
of 38 to 10.
chris we both went back and re-watched
the game
uh because usually we're processing
about a thousand things at the same time
around four o'clock eastern on sunday
was it as bad for aaron rodgers as it
seemed
yes it was it was as bad there's no
doubt
it is as bad as it seemed for the buck i
mean for the the packers football team
as well
you know again i think there's a lot of
things that are concerning
when the big picture of the packers are
talking about super bowl contention
and can they you know beat the the upper
class of the nfl and the nfc and all
those things
yeah i think there is some issues there
hey the first first two drives of the
game
they go down they get 10 points you know
it looked like it was you know
like clockwork on tv but when you watch
on film mike
you realize it was rogers kind of
extending plays getting out of the
pocket it wasn't the offense delivering
he made a few plays by himself and hit
some people down the field as he
scrambled manipulating the coverage
got the bucks and blitz a few times
things like that but after that
i mean of course he makes a mistake that
we don't ever really see him make
and that put them in a tough spot and
then devonte adams into a tight window
interception down the two-yard line
rogers though from that point on just
was not himself he was not
and i think between the the the beast
the bucks have up front and being around
him and collapsing the pocket
and as fast as they are at linebacker
and then these dbs as they settled in
they had no fear of the packers wide
receivers i mean
zero you saw it on the first
interception you know jamal dean he
didn't move he was just sitting there
he's going out
damonte adams if he runs by me i'll
catch him i'm not worried about it
there was no fear there and yes rogers
was rattled the offense was rattled
and i they were really outclassed by the
buccaneers in my opinion did you feel
that way too
yeah and on that first interception yeah
i'd love to know what was
firing through the synapses in aaron
rodgers brain because he gave the ball a
quick pat did you notice that yeah
before he threw it he gave it a quick
pat and he doesn't do that very often
and is he thinking ah what the hell is
he thinking i got this
it was just kind of an odd little
gesture because
you juxtapose it against pick six
everything seems normal he does that
quick patty fires it and it's gone the
other way and it happened in the blink
of an eye
and as he said himself those don't
happen very often to him
and they don't that's what makes it so
jarring i watch that thing like 10 times
and it doesn't want to process because
like aaron rodgers doesn't do this but i
kept seeing that little pat of the ball
and i just love to know
what he's thinking in that instant where
he gives it that quick pat and he lets
it go
because something went wrong there yeah
right and it doesn't happen to him
i think well he was well yeah i mean it
did but you're right it doesn't happen
often
i think he was sitting there going this
guy's i'm going to pat the ball because
once he sees devonte adams another foot
or two away from him he's going to be
scared he's going to run a go route
and he'll turn his hips and give me the
out route and jamel dean just said no
i can kind of see you and i can really
run he's really fast
and i think he just had a good look of
where rogers was in the pocket
devonte adams body language and then the
big thing to me was
you know once rogers recognized it was
tight coverage he didn't throw the
normal roger i just
if he released the rocket maybe he gets
it in there but it's kind of like he
tried to
place it a little bit he didn't just
totally fire it
uh that was the one thing that jumped
out to me but that interception mike
you know we get the next one which is a
little unlucky but it's still it's
it's carlton davis who's another stud
corner all over davonte adams
we we've seen that flagged before right
we have we had the arm he had the arm
around his back
yeah he's reaching over the front we've
seen that flag yeah yep you're you're
right
but you know again when you when you
make a living throwing balls into tight
windows like that as they do so often
that's gonna happen every now and then
too right happened last year
last play of the game against the eagles
they tried to throw a slant like that
down and close to the end zone
popped up in the air i believe it was
intercepted so uh
that but i think the the big thing to me
more than anything is
now it's 14 10 bucks right and rogers
has two opportunities to hit some big
plays down the field
aaron jones drops a ball on the sideline
that i think rogers could have thrown a
little bit better
and then there was mercedes lewis wide
open down the middle
and that was like the one and only point
where you went oh i think
green bay could have maybe stolen some
momentum back from the football game
and they weren't unable to there and i
think it was because rod rodgers was
yeah he was a little rattled by the pass
rush of course his mistakes he's human
that way
and from that point on it was night
night the buccaneers just
obliterated them from that standpoint
and just physically pushed them around
every which way they wanted to do
i want to give carlton davis some credit
though i think he broke up the aaron
jones catch on this the one that was
originally ruled out
right i think davis had something to do
with that ball coming out
it wasn't just a a classic drop but then
rogers did miss
mercedes lewis and as you're watching
the game and you know it's like you know
how the book ends
but you still are working your way
through the chapters to understand why
it went the way it did
that was the first moment he seemed
rattled to me that drive and
why wouldn't he be right two
interceptions but everything's fine it's
ten nothing hey we're going to show tom
brady
oh crap it's 14 to 10 but he did seem
rattled and i think you're right in the
early drives even though they scored
i think he got a sense this has a chance
to maybe be a little more
painful to me than normal games because
i'm i'm having to run away from some
guys who are pretty damn good yeah
that's right and then they stopped that
you know they
they found a way to kind of keep him in
the pocket they collapsed the pocket
that's you know again
they were able to collapse the pocket
with four
people pretty much all game long and
occasional blitz here and there
uh but we as we know i guess any great
quarterbacks and then todd bowles he's
very creative on the back end he did
some cool things that way
but overall i mean just watching back
the game it didn't make me feel any
better about the packers as a football
team it didn't
they have real flaws they they're you
know their offense yes it lacks weaponry
when they get behind against the really
good teams in football
this is where you go i wish they would
have drafted that receiver in the end of
the first round
because when they get in a game like
this maybe it would have helped to have
you know justin jefferson out there or
some uh
other top end chase clay pool whoever it
want
that would have made the buccaneers have
to think things over a little
differently how they wanted to play the
football game
but you know all in all uh they have to
play with a lead
and that's where it worries me for the
packers as good as they go forward
because physically up front they were
not in the same class on either side of
the ball as the buccaneers
yeah chris another key play came when it
was 21 to 10 the drive
before the gronkowski touchdown that
made it 28 to 10.
packers had the ball third and three on
their own 32.
levante david was shot out of a cannon
to sack aaron rodgers
and it's like nobody even saw him and
and you know there's a certain element
of defensive design
that is aimed at putting guys in spots
where
it's not expected they're going to blitz
but he just ran right by the left tackle
i mean the left tackle focused on the
defensive end devonta
levante david straight in and downwind
aaron rodgers
that drive ends yep and then it's 28 to
10 and once it's 28 to 10 that's that
yeah well that was that you're right
that was and
well balls does a great job of he made
if you heard my clip before this the
illusion of complexity hey two guys
blitz but two guys drop out it confuses
the offensive line
you know to where you know the
quarterback's not sure if he's protected
the offensive lines at a little bit of a
disadvantage that way too you just don't
know where it's going to go and all
those type of things but yes rogers
was definitely feeling the pressure all
day long
and bowles and company do a great job of
disguising
and not tipping their blitzes that's
another thing that jumps out like
you know they they don't when rogers
would do dummy snap counts
you know how we always see defenses kind
of like jump or they show their hand
like oh you know he goes set hot hot hot
and they move like oh where oh i was
going to blitz and now now he's got you
oh you're coming okay let me get in this
play these signals and you're screwed
bulls didn't let rogers do that that was
a big part of the game
they like stayed very still he went
through the dummy snap counts they
didn't move
and then when they knew okay we think
it's real here let's do it
at the last second but between that mike
and then
you know brady and the run game having
their way against that defense and
everything like that that's that's got
to be discouraging for the green bay
packers football team too and that's why
i sit here
and go i'm not saying they're the best
team but the bucks
are definitely in the conversation for
the most well-rounded football team in
the nfc
and they're still a work in progress and
i wouldn't be shocked in three or four
weeks if we were saying no no the best
team in the nfc now is the tampa bay
buccaneers
one other thing i noticed before we talk
more about the tampa bay offense and
specifically rob gronkowski yeah
on the late hit call on endomic and sue
late in the first half and and we only
see flashes we see moments based upon
how they go from camera to camera during
the broadcast
but you know sue just commits a late hit
on aaron rodgers and and
and i'm just i'm just making an
observation i'm not suggesting there's
any type of an issue whatsoever i just
thought it was unusual
billy turner the right tackle like goes
up to sue and is like laughing like
isn't that a moment where you go up to
sue and push him or shove him or
mf him or something you know he just
take a look took a light hit on your
quarterback i just thought it was weird
to see billy turner laughing smiling
jovial
with sue after sue took a late hit on
rogers am i off base yeah no
no yeah mike mike i'm kind of i thought
the whole packers football team was like
that in the game yet the other day like
just a little too
like oh relaxed and we're green bay and
this is going to be a fun
show today against tampa bay and tampa
bay was serious and mad as hell they
they weren't like
you know smiling and laughing brady
wasn't like joking with defensive
lineman and doing any of that
you know that to me is where maybe like
when rogers after the game is going
maybe we needed this wake-up call maybe
we were just thinking we're
like that that was what i took it as
because i did i felt like there was
they were there to have you know put on
a show and the other team was there for
battle and to prove a point to go like
hey we just lost and we're
every bit as damn as good as you and
we'll we might see you again here later
on this year
and we'll we're going to let you know
we're a force to be reckoned with but
uh yeah yeah the attitude the toughness
of the buccaneer i mean of the
uh the the packers it got exposed by the
bucks a little bit yeah on sunday
remember zadaria smith yes at the super
bowl talking about the nfc championship
right something something misfires for
this team when they go on the road for
big games
and they haven't fixed it as good as
they are as good as they are the rest of
the time they go on the road for a big
game and there's something that just
doesn't work and zadaria smith talked to
us about that
very candidly and i think we saw that
play out on sunday against the buccaneer
chris before we get to the goats in a
bad way draft for week six
tom brady in that performance on sunday
you know we
talked a lot about aaron rodgers not
looking all that great how did brady
look to you well i i mean
you know brady i thought look really
really good i do i don't care what the
stats say or anything like that
you know the game wasn't there to be
like just opened up throw it all over
the field
but what i'm encouraged by by the bucks
in general
like bruce arians and company didn't
just you know no risk it no biscuit
we're gonna let zadarius smith and
preston smith rush us and we're still
gonna throw the ball down the field
they managed the game and got a feel for
the game and then got the game the way
they
wanted to and then brady dissection
started
i mean the amazing thing about brady is
you just get them inside the 10 yard
line it's like
it's almost like sometimes you're just
gonna go ah just like forget it he's
gonna throw a touchdown pass
forget it let's move on but they got
gronk going
and mike evans and chris godwin weren't
even healthy i mean they weren't even
themselves
so that just i again the buccaneers
their potential is really
special and i think brady and the
offense are really starting to mold
together
really nicely to where you know it can
be real special here in a few weeks
first half gronk the catches he made
even the touchdown catch he
still had that look of a guy who doesn't
have his legs back
second quarter second half rather i
think it was the first drive 31-yard
catch down the middle that was the first
time he looked like the old gronk to me
i agree
all year i agree and that's that's a
good sign it definitely is
he was definitely as you said said he
was out of the mud a little bit in this
game he was it was
it was at least dried mud and he did
look better and like a little bit more
explosive and
hey getting a few catches getting the
touchdowns i'm sure that'll take a
little bit of the pressure
and make things a little bit better for
him too to where he's a little more free
to go out there and let it you know let
it fly next week too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports